you're one of the most effective people
in the world that attacking the left
and sometimes it can slip into attack in
the group
do you worry that there that's the same
kind of oversimplification that yay is
doing about Jewish people that you can
sometimes do with the left as a group so
when I speak about the left I'm speaking
about a philosophy
I'm not really speaking about individual
human beings as
the leftists like group and then try to
name who the members of this individual
group are I also make a distinction
between the left and liberals there are
a lot of people who are liberal who
disagree with me on taxes disager than
foreign policy disagree with me on a lot
of things the people who I'm talking
about generally and I talk about the
left in the United States are people who
believe that alternative points of view
ought to be silenced because they are
damaging and harmful simply based on the
disagreement so that's one distinction
the second distinction again is when I
talk about the right versus the left
typically I'm talking about a battle of
competing philosophies and so I'm not
speaking about typically
it would be hard to if you put a person
in front of me and said is this person
of the left or of the right having just
met them I wouldn't be able to label
them in the same way that if you met
somebody in the name of Greenstein you'd
immediately got you right I mean a black
person's black person and the the
adherence to a philosophy makes you a
member of
a group if I think the philosophy is bad
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
as a person are bad but it does mean
that I think your philosophy is bad yeah
so the grouping is based on the
philosophy versus something
like a race like this the the color of
your skin or race is in the case of the
Jewish people so it's a different thing
you can be a little bit more nonchalant
and careless and attacking a group
because it's ultimately attacking a set
of ideas well I mean it's really
nonchalant in attacking the set of ideas
and I don't know that nonchalant would
be the way I put it I tried I tried to
be exact when you're you know you don't
you don't always hit but you know the if
I say that I oppose the Communists right
and and then presumably I'm speaking of
people who believe in the Communist
philosophy now the question is whether
I'm mislabeling right whether I'm taking
someone who's not actually a communist
and then shoving them in that group of
Communists right that would be
inaccurate the the dangerous thing is it
expands the group as opposed to you
talking about the philosophy you you're
you're throwing everybody who's ever
said I'm curious about communism I'm
curious about socialism there's because
there's like a gradient you know it's
like uh to throw something at you I
think Joe Biden said mag of Republicans
right right
you know I think that's a very careless
statement because the thing you jump to
immediately is like for Trump right
versus I think
the in the in the charitable
interpretation that means a set of ideas
yeah my actually problem with with the
mega Republicans line from from Biden is
that he went on in the speech that he
made in in front of a dependence Hall to
actually try and Define what it meant to
be American Republican who's a threat to
the Republic was the kind of language
that he was using and later on in the
speech he actually suggested well you
know there are moderate Republicans and
the moderate Republicans are people who
agree with me on like the inflation
reduction acts like well that that can't
be the the dividing line between America
Republican and a moderate like a
moderate Republican somebody who agrees
with you that you got to name me like a
republican who disagrees with you fairly
strenuously but is not in this group of
threats to the Republic you make that
distinction we can have a fair
discussion about whether the idea of
election denial for example make
somebody you know a threat to
institutions that that's that's a that's
a conversation that we can have and then
we'll have to discuss how much power
they have you know what the actual
perspective is what delve into it but
you know I think that he was being over
Broad and sort of labeling all of his
political enemies under one rubric now
again in politics this stuff sort of
happens all the time you're not going to
plead Clean Hands here because I'm sure
that I've been inexact but somebody will
be good in that particular situation is
for somebody just sort of read me back
the quote and I'll let you know where
I've been inaccurate I'll try to do that
and also you don't shy away from humor
and occasional trolling and mockery and
all that kind of stuff for the for the
fun for the chaos all that kind of stuff
I mean you know I I try not to to do
trollery for trollery sake but you know
if the show's not entertaining and not
fun people aren't going to listen and so
you know if you can't have fun with
politics the truth about politics is we
all take it very seriously because it
has some serious ramifications politics
is Veep it is not House of Cards the the
general rule of politics is that
everyone is a [ __ ] unless proven
otherwise that virtually everything is
done out of stupidity rather than malice
and that if you actually watch Politics
as a comedy you'll have a lot more fun
and so the the difficulty for me is I
take politics seriously but also I have
the ability to sort of flip the switch
and suddenly It all becomes incredibly
funny because it it really is like if
you just watch it from pure
entertainment perspective and you put
aside the fact that it affects hundreds
of millions of people then watching
you know
president Trump being president I mean
he's one of the funniest humans who's
ever lived watching Kamala Harris be
Kamala Harris and talking about how much
he loves Venn diagrams or electric buses
I mean that's that's funny stuff so if I
can't make fun of that then my job
becomes pretty morose pretty quickly
yeah it's funny to figure out what is
the perfect balance between
uh seeing the humor and the absurdity of
the game of it versus taking it
seriously enough because it does affect
hundreds of millions of people it's a
weird balance to strike it's like uh I
am afraid with the internet that
everything becomes a joke
I totally agree with this I I will say
this I I try to make less
jokes about the ideas and more jokes
about the people in the same way that I
make jokes about myself I'm pretty
self-effacing in terms of my humor and I
would say at least half the drugs on my
show are about me
right when I'm when I'm reading ads for
for Tommy John and they're talking about
their no as you guarantee I'll say
things like you know that would help me
in high school because it would have I
mean just factually speaking um so you
know that if I can speak that way about
myself I feel like everybody else can
take it as well